no no veo yo tal vez como un grupo claro
ese gran grupo de la muerte tal vez el
grupo con españa alemania japón y bueno
quien que también hay de repechaje es
ese que ese grupo tal vez pueda ser como
el más difícil en todo caso para que
españa y alemania avancen a sabiendas de
que a japón por lo general siempre es un
equipo bastante difícil
recordemos japón que siempre pues ha
complicado la vida de los buenos equipos
a colombia le complicó la vida en a
rusia perdiendo ese ese partido en la
fase de grupos yo tal vez diría que ese
podría ser tal vez el parte del equipo
el grupo de pronto un poco el grupo más
difícil ahora tal vez en el grupo a
salvo catar los otros 13 equipos de
ecuador senegal y países bajos pues ahí
puede haber una buena disputa pero no sé
tal vez no se ve claro como usted lo
decía tal vez no se ve claro un grupo de
la muerte como por lo general logramos
tener en este tipo de competiciones de
natalia muchísimas gracias por habernos
acompañado ahí en esa falsa ahora que
vemos en parís con todavía mucho frío
paulo para ir terminando de la misma
pregunta muy rápidamente tenemos o no
tenemos grupo de la muerte en ese
mundial me parece que el más parejo es
el último y portugal gana hungría
uruguay y corea del sur me parece que es
un grupo muy parejo esperemos cómo se
resuelve portugal ese grupo